gallon is the whole you characterize
this year's decision by the Nobel
Committee well this is in a long
tradition the disarmament tradition
point to you now from the bells will and
the norwegian nobel committee has
awarded several many prices to those who
work for the abolition of nuclear
weapons this year we focus on chemical
weapons this year's prize be compared to
the one in 1997 when the international
campaign against landmines got the price
yes this one the landmine tradition was
also in the disarmament part of the
disarmament aspect but I would compare
this primarily to the abolition of
nuclear weapons weapons of mass
destruction we have had 67 prices at
least to those who for it for the
abolition of nuclear weapons this is the
first for the abolition of capital this
could be described as a disarmament
price very much so right in the center
of alpha Annabel's will do you think it
will be regarded as a non-controversial
price well there are always some who
criticize the norwegian nobel committee
because they would have preferred other
candidates but i think there will be a
great deal of understanding and sympathy
for this year's price many pioneers of
movements for the peeps movements many
statesmen and all the politicians many
humble people working for human rights
has got the price historically how
important it is a surprise today I think
it's very important but it doesn't
create a new category so to speak but
the committee has always been concerned
about after niveles we'll all the
members know the world and even when
we've been criticized for not abiding by
the world
committee has I mean take the most
criticized prizes the two for the
environment and there are those who
argue that this was not really part of
alfred nobel's will but point one in
alpha Annabelle's will is promoting
fraternity between nations I mean if
saving the planet if stopping included
or limiting climate change is not
fraternity between nations what is
fraternity between nations so yes ultra
the bells will but we must also be able
to address contemporary concerns the
nobel peace prize is the most
prestigious the most important among all
the about 300 peace prizes in the world
why is it still so i think it's a
combination of factors we have been
doing this for a very long period I mean
since nineteen hundred and one so this
is our 112 year we're in a family of
prices the Nobel family and everybody
benefits from this family relationship I
think our selections through these 112
years they have not been perfect but
they have been solid respectable there
are emissions there may be some who
shouldn't have receive the price but
overall this has gone surprisingly well
and we have been able to adjust over
these years I mean make the price truly
global include more women widen open the
definitions in Alton the bells will a
bit more I think it's a combination of
all these you have been a leading
personnel this house for about 23 years
next year in general next year you are
69 well next year but your loss as the
director of the noble institute and and
search also a secretary of the committee
yes I will be here throughout 2014 but
from 2015 somebody else will take over I
will write about my splendid years my
wonderful 24 25 years here that's what I
will do as my retirement project number
one if you are looking back on your 23
years working here
what are the highlights every year is a
highlight it's very difficult to kind of
rank them but I mean the change from
being a history professor at the world's
northernmost University in Trump's ax
and to having Gorbachev as my first
lorient so to speak that change was huge
so that made a very special impression
on me naturally but they are they're all
all the laureates are wonderful a people
and organizations they're very different
some are very far to the left some are
quite far to the right I think what they
have in common are two things they have
a vision they want to go somewhere they
have an objective they want to reach and
most them show considerable courage in
trying to reach or fulfill that vision